we will now formulate the clustering
problems that we define informally in
the previous section
as a rigorous computational problem
and i think good clustering should
satisfy
the good clustering principle which says
that
elements within the same cluster should
be closer to each other
than elements in different clusters or
in other words there should be a
parameter
delta such that distance between
elements
in the same cluster is less than delta
and distance between elements in
different clusters
is larger than data for example
is it a clustering satisfying is a good
clustering principle
of course not because there are elements
in the same cluster
that are further away from each other
that elements in different cost
however this problem is easy to fix
because here is the clustering
satisfying the good clustering principle
and therefore we come up with
the following clustering problem find
a partition of expression vector into
cluster
that satisfies the good clustering
principle
but how about the example below this
slide
can we construct clustering satisfying
the good clustering principle
it turns out that doesn't matter how
much we try
there is no partition satisfying the
good clustering
principle for this data set which means
that the problems that we just
formulated
why it is a well-defined computational
problem
it is essentially useless for most
practical data sets
because most of them do not have a
partition
satisfying the good clustering principle
thus we have to figure out how to
construct
a new objective function for clustering
that will generate a solution for
any data set here is small data set of
four points
and four different ways to cluster it
which of them is the best clustering
our goal now is to come up with the
notion
of the objective function for clustering
and to do this i will take liberty to
reformulate
the goal of clustering into an
equivalent goal of finding
centers of cluster for example below
you can see data set consisting
of eight blue points and three
points representing centers of clusters
for this data set
our goal is to come up with the notion
of
distance between data and centers and
then after we come up with the notion of
distance between data and centers
we want to find centers that minimize
this distance but what is
the distance from data to center to
define
the notion of distance from data to
centers we will
first define the notion of distance from
a single data point
to centers and in this case it's natural
to define this distance as the distance
from a data point
to its closest center for example
the distance from this blue point uh
will be the distance to close the center
and we can construct
distances to all
fall data points in this way now
we only define the distance from a
single data point to centers
our goal now is to define the distance
from
all data points to center what would be
the natural notion of such distance
and i think maximum distance among the
distances we just computed
would be the natural notion of distance
between data and center
that's how we define max distance
objective function
for clustering after we define the
notion of max distance
we are ready to formulate the k center
clustering problem
given a set of points data find
k centers minimizing maximum distance
between data and center you see at the
bottom of the slide an example with
eight blue point and
three centers these three centers are
very poorly chosen as a solution of case
center clustering problem
this centers would be a better solution
but
is it the optimal solution of the case
center clustering problem
actually not because there is a
different partition of points into
cluster
that gives even better solution of the
case center clustering problem
anyway it appears case center
transferring problem appears to be
a rather simple problem but it turns out
that it's actually np complete and
therefore we have to develop an
approximation algorithm
for solving it and our next task is to
present
case center clustering heuristic that is
called
the fastest first traversal the fastest
first traversal start from
choosing an arbitrary point as the first
center of the cluster as the next step
which
point would you choose as the
next center the reasonable approach is
to choose the point
that is furthest apart from the existing
cluster
which will be this point afterwards
we find the distances from the already
constructed clusters
to all data points and to choose the
next cluster
we simply select the distance that is
largest among the constructed distances
and this is our third cluster if we only
need to construct three cluster we are
done
and this is clustering a partitioning of
eight point into three clusters that k
fastest the father's first reversal
produce
now after we design the father's first
traversal algorithm
let's ask question what is wrong with
this algorithmic practice
well the father's first traversal select
centers
that minimize maximum distance
but biologists are often interested in
typical
rather than maximal distances because
maximum distances often represent
experimental errors or
outliers for example in this case
of a simple clustering problem that is
presented below
let's see how human eye and father's
first traversal
would solve the uh problem the human eye
will immediately cs3 cluster and will
ignore outlier
the fastest first reversal on the other
hand
will always construct three clusters
and means the correct clustering of
points
these are foreign need to develop a
different approach
to clustering that works well with these
outliers to come up with a new
clustering approach we first need to
modify the objective
function for clustering our max distance
objective function designed for the case
clustering problem
has its limitation please note that only
one of distances
shown below contributes to max distance
instead we will use a new objective
function
called the squared error distortion the
square error distortion
is sum of squares
of all distances divided by the number
of points in the data set
so for the maximum distance
a single data point contributes to the
objective function
while for the distortion all data points
contribute to the objective function as
as soon as we define the squared
distortion
we define the k-means clustering problem
and the only difference between k-center
clustering problem
and the k-means clustering problem is
that the k-means clustering problem
tries to optimize distortion rather
that maximum distance in this case
the centers chosen shown at this slide
are not good centers and after we apply
case center
clustering problem they will move to
different points
after the applied k-means clustering
problem they
also will move to different points and
please note
that they have moved to different
position
than in the case center clustering
problem
now it may appear that k-means
clustering problem is simple
but it turned out to be np-hard
even for partitioning a set of data
points
into just two clusters
the only case when the polynomial
algorithm for k-means clustering problem
is the case when k equal to one
you may think that there is no point to
cluster data sets into one cluster
because this clustering
is given indeed we are not trying to
cluster data set into one cluster we are
trying to find
the best center of this cluster and you
will see in the next section
that it will be actually very helpful
however how do we find a center of a
cluster
so how do we how do we develop algorithm
for k-means clustering
when k equal to 1 when
in this case there is the center of
gravity theorem
which tell that the center of gravity of
points data is the only point remember
only is important here
the only point solving the one means
clustering problem
to remind you the center of gravity of
points data if we represent every point
as a vector is simply the sum
of these vectors divided over the number
of vectors in the data sets
or in other words the i's coordinate
of the center of gravity is simply the
average
of the ice coordinates of all points
in the data set and now after we
introduce uh the notion of k-means
clustering we are ready to describe the
lloyd algorithm
the most popular approximation algorithm
for solving the k-means clustering
problem